right here i've graphed part of the
graph of y is equal to 1 over x and what
i'm curious about is the area under this
curve and above the x-axis between
x equals 1 and infinity so i want to
figure out this area
right over here so let's try to do it so
we could set this up as an improper
integral going from 1
to
infinity
of 1 over x
1 over x
dx
well we can once again we can view this
as the limit
the limit actually do that same yellow
color i like that more we can view this
as the limit
as n approaches infinity
of
the integral from 1 to n of 1 over x
dx
which we can write as the limit
as n approaches infinity of the
anti-derivative 1 over x which is the
natural log of the absolute value of x
so this is going to be the natural log
of the absolute value of x
and the absolute value of x won't really
matter so much we could just say x
because we're dealing with positive
values of x but i'll just write down as
the natural log of the absolute value of
x
between
x is 1 and x is n
and so this is going to be equal to the
limit as n approaches infinity of you
evaluate this at n so you're going to
get the natural log i could write the
absolute value of n but we know that n
is going to be positive so we can just
write the natural log of n
minus the natural log of the absolute
value of 1 or the natural log of one
natural log of one is just zero e to the
zero power is equal to one so this boils
down to the limit
as n approaches infinity of the natural
log of n
now this is interesting natural log
function just keeps getting larger and
larger and larger it kind of natural log
function looks something like
keeps growing and growing and growing
like this
albeit at a at a slower and slower pace
but it keeps growing the limit as n
approaches infinity of the natural log
of n is just equal to
infinity
so here we do not have a finite area
this is an infinite
this is an infinite area it's
interesting when this function decreased
faster when it was 1 over x squared we
had a finite area now we have an
infinite area and so we would say that
this integral right over here is this
improper integral is divergent
divergent and we're done